all right let's go on to the next
category then well this is quite fitting
uh because it's one that is close to my
heart yeah that's the saltiest moment
yes
i had to take the jacket off for this
one yeah
because it's going to get hot
here yeah so let's see what the
nominations are yeah yeah all right we
have connor not winning the cooking
special
this is definitely sold this is a salty
moment that has persisted to this day
yeah connor to this day has not let mail
in government that's true yeah
uh gant learns that the dead sea is a
lake
i'm pretty salty about that
i think we were all serious
i didn't vote for that so i i i didn't
care uh conor not getting points because
of his own rules oh this is the feel
good ink one right oh this was the field
goal
you were very it was it was like that
was one of the rare times when it was
just like i could it was like real real
i was shocked i don't know why i was so
salty for that part like i didn't
normally i wouldn't give a [ __ ] actually
so i think it's because you you realized
you [ __ ] yourself over but normally i
wouldn't care before this time for some
reason i cared so much about it
because like because like this this
exact moment was like energy of just
like little brother is just like [ __ ]
like like it was like i told you to get
off the xbox you're just like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right fine
uh the boys finding out they gave
budweiser
shameful that is a shameful moment we
were very salty about it we were salty
about i love how none of these uh are
from normal episodes
oh yeah because we're not salty now
one's from a special and the other yeah
yeah
we're way salty on after dark
i feel like the amount of times we argue
about answers in half the dark i feel
like you can i feel like four or four
categories just isn't enough sometimes
you know i'm shocked that some of the
figure special stuff wasn't in here that
was a very salty special oh sure yeah
yeah yeah well like trying to decide
like delegate like points
i believe that was like more
i think we're going to see it again on
like the best arguments because like
because i think like how do you
distinguish between salty and arguments
right
the level of anger with an argument yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but i believe
these for saltiest moments i believe if
they're because none of these arguments
right yeah so i think it's like they're
just temper tantrums yeah they're just
these are just tantrums okay meline's
scoring of mine and god so it's actually
utter [ __ ]
i love that i love my face
ben
so i can't remember what she said but
she did come on to defend herself on
trash days after dark i don't remember
what episode that was which one do you
think is gonna win
this is hard holy [ __ ] i really don't
know like this is one of the hardest
ones right because they are all
really really salty moments
like my god i'm probably going to say
just purely from the fact that it was
like the most infamous moment in trash
taste i would say the bodwish one could
be could because that one got me to [ __ ]
yeah i think it's gonna be either that
one or the cooking special maybe i don't
know i don't know
i don't think it's gonna be the dead so
do we have do we have clips to play with
this yep okay so shall we see how salty
we look in the clips yeah let's see yeah
that means i won
let's go
it's all right gone you you tied with
connor yeah absolute joke come here come
here come on come on i don't want to see
you my fellow man how much you pay me
lean huh how much you pay me lead huh
[ __ ] up
like like like like uh
physically no on camera it doesn't look
like corn is that salty but connor was
very connor was actually salty on camera
like off camera he just he just like
that's like he got saltier as like the
time went on like
it was like fine wine but just like with
salt you know it just aged more as time
went on
all right so we play the gun loans about
the dead sea it's not a lake it's a salt
lake
wait so what
what
sorry sorry let me just i am losing
brain cells
right now
where you would call
a landlocked lake
the dead sea
i think that's the only time in trash
takes history where god has clipped the
audio
oh my god people listening on headphones
i think i was just so disgusted i was
just like like you know when you just
realize like like something has very
gone wrong something has gone wrong with
the system you literally threw down the
white ball like what the i'm like the
world is broken like what is the point
anymore you know people often lie
i've i discovered that today all right
let's play uh conor not getting points
because of his own rules i don't want
the point i just don't want god to get
the people great agreement we both get
the point and job gets nothing let's
feel good inc i got gorillas feel good
what was that that you said to me
literally like two three questions ago
i'll give you a point for gorillas you
said that you need to just get the songs
[Applause]
i think that wasn't like so much a salty
moment as much as it like persisted for
like a few rounds after that yeah if we
had an instant karma uh award then yeah
that would absolutely win yeah all right
and then uh the boys find out they gave
budweiser a seven point five we want to
forget about this
to czech one okay i said it's the check
one as well i don't know the german
beers so i'm just 50 50. it tastes
german all right ready okay three two
one
no
no no
no
no
how does this taste good
that like i like like i
i remember like i don't know if that's
salty because you can you can really
feel the despair in the third no that i
shouted that that was like an oscar
award worthy like no
i was like that's some real [ __ ] right
there you know how they say like no is
like unrealistic dialogue
you shouldn't include in your script
that's obviously not true that's some
real [ __ ] right there there's true
despair right there if you're feeling
true dismay yes you do shout out no
oh my god yeah now that i think about it
it's probably it might have a chance of
winning but like that was not so much
salty as that was just like shame that
was shame and despair all right let's
find out then i guess yeah jacket is off
for this one the winner is
connor not getting the points
you know what that's worthy that's
pretty worth it that is worthy that is
worthy
what were the percentages for that this
was really close oh i'm not surprised
this was one of this is probably the
hardest category this is the hardest one
yeah uh connor you won with
31.6 percent of the vote okay
and you came in second as well with one
point one percent of the vote or five
point four not winning the cooking
special i'll take that i'll tell you
that
[Laughter]
anyone who can be saltier than me
and then which one was better budweiser
older uh budweiser was third with thirty
point nine percent of the vote oh wow
wait what the dead sea one get there
let's see came in with six point four
percent of the vote wow damn that was
like a three like a three horse race
then yeah i mean that's like i i thought
the dead sea one would get a little bit
more because like that's a rare sight
where gaunt is salty yeah like you don't
often see that
all right wow that was very close all
right next up next one is the most
monkey award
well uh we're probably gonna expect uh
like about six nominations from i've
completely forgotten the nominations of
this okay first one is oh it's one of
two okay there's quite a few yeah all
right the first one is the boy's not
running away from a gas canister in the
campfire
that was done
that was the rare moment where conor was
not the monkey yeah that's when we're
going like conor was like the
neanderthal to us like us monkeys at
that point you know like he he was like
more involved than us
higher than you
wait play no i play the clip play the
the torch was catching on fire the gas
canister is right next to you i'm like
oh oh oh fire plus can i backed off i
was like running away these boys are
sitting there watching watches not
helping yeah
just watching this guy holding this gas
canister on fire i mean yeah it was
pretty it was pretty scary and i think a
lot of people like this because this is
like one of the most viewed like tick
tocks right i think so yeah well like it
it initially was one of our most tick
tocks by the way follow us on tick tock
yeah and youtube shorts as well youtube
shorts
connor bought four tier figures
yeah that was pretty monkey yeah i did
forget about that rule yeah yeah do
connor's four deal figures count as only
one duplicate um so
basically yeah uh you know how
[Laughter]
i'm about to hear [ __ ] right now you
know an argument is going to be strong
when it starts with um so basically yeah
i was trying to there was some decent
excuse but there was none i just
completely forgot about that rule yeah
yeah yeah until
you know until after it was over because
what makes it even more monkey is that
you would have clearly been like ahead
in the race because you were like
clearly ahead in points and then you
just kept like deducting points from
yourself like because of you because you
bought so many d.o figures
so funny all right next one is god
forgets how to do long division play the
clip calculate 111
111 divided by 11. [ __ ]
i'm hoping god will get this one because
i did oh wait i should i should i'll be
honest actually i've forgotten you know
what i i i have forgotten i just broke
the [ __ ] beer starting to hit me man
i should have had i should have had more
than the salad
i mean in in ghance defense apparently
after that stream finished i was like
watching back on the episode apparently
i just did it completely wrong but i
still somehow got the correct answer so
i mean i mean i don't know why i don't
know i mean i don't know why it's god
forgets how to do long division because
me and connor are like
me and connor are in the same boat here
well technically i forgot as well
because i didn't even do it right
because like we at least you like had
like a decent attempt yeah i believe
like me and connor just like gave up
even
like the two engineers here like we just
couldn't figure it out
there's a calculator in it yeah
exactly yeah
uh the boys get confused by the richter
scale oh yeah it's just very recent one
there's a reason why
whoever designed the richter scale
really [ __ ] up it's not uh linear do
you mean exponential expert i think
that's what i think logarithmic is
exponential oh it is logarithmic thank
you okay but you were trying to explain
exponentially i'm smart
you said the right word but you were
saying the wrong thing the original
point i was trying to make was that they
you they put it in a scale that is not
comprehensible by the normal human
person which
right now
i mean like compared to the others i
would say this is on like the lower end
right yeah because okay we were arguing
like actually both me and connor were
both right and we were both wrong yeah
yeah in in a sense here we because i was
like oh i said the richter scale was a
logarithmic scale which it is i didn't
realize that logarithms are the opposite
of exponentials which they are so those
are like
those are two different things i
remember i read up on it after the
episode yeah i still didn't get it the
fact that we needed actual like
mathematicians to do like a [ __ ]
three paragraph long explanation of it
just proves that you know it's it might
not be the most monkey moments maybe
because we are engineers they would
expect higher you know it's not
recommendable
when you when you've got an engineering
degree but you don't use it for like six
years you're the kind of
kind of yeah you kind of forget look man
i can't do logarithm i can't do [ __ ]
long divisions what makes you think i
know what a [ __ ] logarithmic scale is
you know
we got a couple of other nominees
oh did we really yeah that was one of
two oh wow okay so this one is the boy
scream jojo drink counter i love this
clip i stand
that was like the rare moment where we
all shared the same brainstorm not just
like me and joey that was like yeah that
was like we literally de-evolved into
monkeys i i think that's like the most
probably the most monkey right there
honestly just jojo pants in a nutshell
am i right god and joey share the same
brain cells oh we only have one clip of
this yeah we got like some of the
biggest bangers have had the girlfriend
in the title we've got domestic
girlfriend we've got rent a girlfriend
girlfriend
there's girlfriend many other moments i
mean this is the feeling i i feel like
there's no one moment it's just like
just every moment where we like that was
one like there was a subtle moment where
i said the same thing i have to ask that
why does god get scared by his own
history what is that
i think that's from the camping story
right oh
i think something's wrestling in the
body
play the clip though one of you guys say
something funny start laughing i look
over and i'm just like you know the boys
are just being boys i look back over and
i see some things someone's breath just
like just like going towards like a
white cloud yeah like a white cloud i'm
like [ __ ] there's there's a monster
hiding in that bush and then i soon
realized literally half a second in that
it's just my piss steaming
[Music]
that's that has to be top three right i
mean that has to be told that was like
very monkey that was neanderthal being
scared of like wild animals you know i
was like i was like
my favorite story is just like imagining
it like in context right you just turn
around
oh it's just my pee
because i was slightly intoxicated at
that point and i was just
i mean like
i do still feel
the jojo moment is the most i wouldn't
be disappointed if it wasn't the georgia
one i don't think it will be you don't
think so what do you think so what do
you think
i don't know actually there's a lot yeah
there's a lot of good stuff here all
right well let's find out there all
right right here so the winner for the
most monkey moment goes to
god gets scared by his own peers
[Music]
that is the most that's pretty [ __ ]
monkey to be fair all right all right i
didn't say it was interesting
the monkey award for this year you got
the monkey award give me give me that
give me that okay i'll take it i'll tell
you
i'll take that home we'll take that one
i'll take that one all right all the
percentages are
uh got one that one with
uh hold on
twenty seven point two percent of the
vote
okay yeah okay there was more
nominations here yeah
top four top four oh yours obviously was
the first second was the boys not
running away from a gas canister with
21.6 percent
third was gone and joey sharing one
brain cell with 19.6 percent of the vote
and in fourth place connor with his four
dio figures at 13.
all right what's the next category then